Although we are currently in the midst of a global pandemic, we should not forget that we are fortunate to live in a time where we have vaccines and other public health measures we can take to avoid illnesses such as polio, smallpox, cholera, even bubonic plague. And we hope that soon COVID-19 will be vanquished by vaccines. But for our ancestors, infectious diseases were a constant danger, so much so that the threat of infection has actually helped shape human evolution. Disgust, wariness of strangers, cultural norms around food and cleanliness, all of these behaviors may have evolved, at least in part, to keep us safe from infectious disease. Researchers call this suite of protective mechanisms the behavioral immune system, but are the defenses that humans evolved thousands of years ago to ward off infection suitable to protect us from the diseases we face today?
尽管我们目前正处于一场全球大流行之中，但我们不应忘记，我们很幸运能生活在这样一个时代：我们拥有疫苗和其他公共卫生措施，可以用来预防脊髓灰质炎、天花、霍乱甚至鼠疫等疾病。我们希望新冠肺炎也能很快被疫苗战胜。但对我们的祖先来说，传染病是一种持续存在的危险，以至于感染的威胁实际上帮助塑造了人类的进化。厌恶感、对陌生人的警惕、围绕食物和清洁的文化规范，所有这些行为的演变，至少有一部分是为了保护我们免受传染病的侵害。研究人员将这一套保护机制称为行为免疫系统，但是人类在数千年前进化出的用于抵御感染的防御机制，是否适合保护我们免受当今面临的疾病的侵害？
Do they do more harm than good in some cases? and what is the role of disgust in keeping us safe and healthy? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Mark Schaller, a professor of psychology at the University of British Columbia.
在某些情况下，它们到底是利大于弊还是弊大于利？厌恶感在保持我们安全和健康方面起着什么作用？欢迎收看《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是英属哥伦比亚大学心理学教授马克·沙勒博士。
Dr. Schaller coined the term behavioral immune system, and he studies how the perceived threat of disease has shaped human psychology. He's also interested more broadly in human social cognition, stereotyping, evolutionary psychology, and cultural psychology. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Schaller. Hey, thank you for having me. I'm delighted to be here. Let's start with a broad question. What exactly is the behavioral immune system and how and why did it evolve?
沙勒博士创造了“行为免疫系统”一词，他研究了人们对疾病的感知威胁如何塑造人类心理。他还对更广泛的人类社会认知、刻板印象、进化心理学和文化心理学感兴趣。非常感谢您今天能参加我们的节目，沙勒博士。嘿，谢谢你们邀请我。我很高兴能来到这里。让我们从一个广泛的问题开始。究竟什么是行为免疫系统？它是如何以及为什么进化的？
The behavioral immune system, I think, can be kind of thought of as a suite of psychological responses that evolved to help defend against the threat of infection. diseases and it's comprised of psychological mechanisms that help us detect potentially infectious things in the immediate environment to respond to those things in a way that might help us avoid them and therefore to help keep us from getting sick. The second part of your question, why do we even have this set of mechanisms? When I think of this, I think of it, it's useful to think about the benefits as well as the costs of what we might think of as the real immune system. You know, our immunological defenses against infections kick in when those things, bacteria, viruses, whatever, when they get inside us. And it's awesome that we have these immunological
我认为，行为免疫系统可以被看作是一套心理反应，它们的进化是为了帮助防御感染的威胁。它由一些心理机制组成，这些机制帮助我们在紧邻的环境中检测潜在的传染源，以某种有助于我们避开这些传染源的方式作出反应，从而帮助我们免于生病。你问题的第二部分是，为什么我们甚至会拥有这一套机制？当我想到这一点时，我认为思考我们所谓的真正免疫系统的益处和成本是很有用的。你知道，我们对抗感染的免疫防御会在这些东西（细菌、病毒或其他东西）进入我们体内时启动。拥有这些免疫系统真是太棒了
defenses that can mount a defense against those things. But it's hugely costly. And to actually mount an immunological defense against bacteria and so forth. It consumes an enormous amount of caloric resources. It can be debilitating. It prevents us from doing all kinds of other things. So in a sense, I think you can think of what we call our immune system is kind of like medical insurance. It's great to have, but it really stinks when we have to use it.
这些防御能够针对这些东西发起防御。但代价是巨大的。要真正针对细菌等启动免疫防御，它会消耗大量的热量资源。这可能是令人衰弱的。它会阻止我们做各种其他事情。所以从某种意义上说，我认为你可以把我们所谓的免疫系统看作是一种医疗保险。有固然很好，但当我们不得不使用它时，感觉真的很糟。
It'd be better not to have to use it at all. And that's where the behavioral immune system comes into play. It's a kind of a form of preventative medicine. These mechanisms help prevent us from having to actually mount that costly immunological defense and so serves as kind of a complementary kind of defense against the threat of infectious diseases. You found that one of the biggest implications of this system is how it affects our interactions with other people, particularly people who are different from us in some way. What is the relationship between the behavioral immune system and prejudice or xenophobia?
最好根本不用使用它。这就是行为免疫系统发挥作用的地方。这是一种预防医学。这些机制有助于防止我们真正去发动那种代价高昂的免疫防御，因此可以作为一种针对传染病威胁的补充性防御。你发现这个系统最大的影响之一是它如何影响我们与他人的互动，特别是那些在某些方面与我们不同的人。行为免疫系统与偏见或仇外心理之间有什么关系？
Generally speaking, when people are more concerned about the threat of disease, if they feel more vulnerable to infection, they tend to respond more harshly to people who look different, to people who act different, to strangers, to people who they perceive as being from strange or different places. And there's a couple of different reasons why that might be. One is this idea that historically people from who are strange or from strange different places might have been more likely to bring with them more exotic parasites, things that are more likely to make us sick. And that might be possible.
总的来说，当人们对疾病威胁更加关注，如果他们感到更容易受到感染，他们往往会对看起来不同的人、行为不同的人、陌生人以及他们认为来自陌生或不同地方的人做出更严厉的反应。这背后有几个不同的原因。其中一个原因是，历史上那些奇怪的或来自奇怪的不同地方的人，可能更有可能随身携带更多异国情调的寄生虫，这些寄生虫更有可能让我们生病。这可能是可能的。
But I actually think a less obvious answer is probably a more compelling answer to the question, which has to do with the first. fact that a lot of the things that people historically have done in order to avoid infection had to do with doing things a certain way. Prepare food a certain way. We have these norms of hygiene, and we have norms that govern what are appropriate ways of engaging in intimate, interpersonal contact with other folks. So we have these rituals and norms. And prior to contemporary technological advances in medicine and pharmacology and public health, these kind of rituals and norms were kind of most of what people had to help them figure out how to avoid coming into contact with infectious diseases.
但我实际上认为，一个不太显而易见的答案可能是一个更引人注目的答案，这与第一个事实有关，即历史上人们为了避免感染而做的很多事情都与以某种特定方式做事有关。以某种特定方式准备食物。我们有这些卫生规范，我们有规范来管理与其他人进行亲密的人际接触的适当方式。所以我们有这些仪式和规范。在当代医学、药学和公共卫生技术进步之前，这类仪式和规范可以说是人们拥有的全部，用以帮助他们弄清楚如何避免接触传染病。
Which means that anybody who is likely to violate those norms to do things differently, to prepare food differently, to violate, you know, violate norms of. sanitation and hygiene, they posed a threat not just to themselves, but to anybody in the community. So people who seem likely to act different, people who are from foreign lands, it may kind of activate the sense of these people don't do the things that we're likely to do. And so getting back to your question, the idea is that this kind of xenophobic response to people who are different maybe have historically served the function of trying to avoid and keep away people who would violate local rituals and social norms. So some of these things sound like they could be traditions, things that would be passed down from generation to generation, but was there something going way, way back that maybe the humans who prepared food in a certain way just tended to survive,
这意味着任何可能违反这些规范、以不同方式做事、违反卫生规范的人，不仅对自己构成了威胁，也对社区中的任何人构成了威胁。因此，那些看起来可能会做出不同行为的人，那些来自外国的人，可能会激活这样一种感觉：这些人不做我们可能会做的事情。所以回到你的问题，这个想法是，这种对不同之人的仇外反应，在历史上可能起到了试图避开和驱逐那些会违反当地仪式和社会规范的人的功能。所以其中一些事情听起来像是传统，代代相传的事情，但有没有什么可以追溯到很久很久以前的事情，也许那些以某种特定方式准备食物的人只是倾向于生存下来，
and therefore it got passed along in that way, almost like an instinctive thing? I wouldn't say an instinctive thing, but more of a kind of a superstitious thing. So food preparation is one of my favorite examples of this, because biologists who have studied spices have found that the use of culinary spices is a natural form of antibiotic. It's not just hot peppers, but just about every kind of herb and spice that people use to flavor food actually has some anti-bacterial properties. And so what's likely to have happened is that people just kind of through trial and error
因此它就以这种方式流传下来，几乎就像一种本能的东西？我不会说这是一种本能的东西，而更像是一种迷信的东西。所以食物准备是我最喜欢的例子之一，因为研究香料的生物学家发现，烹饪香料的使用是一种天然的抗生素。不仅是红辣椒，人们用来给食物调味的几乎每一种草药和香料实际上都有一些抗菌特性。所以可能发生的情况是，人们只是通过反复试验
kind of figured out that, hey, if we prepare food in this kind of way, you know, we put hot spices on our meat, then people are less likely to get sick. Nobody really knew why, right? Yeah. Yeah. Way back when before people even had a concept of germ theory. But I mean, you know, you can figure out, all right, people get sick if we prepare food this way and they don't, if we prepare food this other way.
有点琢磨出来，嘿，如果我们以这种方式准备食物，你知道，我们在肉上放辣香料，那么人们生病的可能性就会降低。没有人真正知道为什么，对吧？是的。是的。早在人们甚至还没有细菌理论概念的时候。但我的意思是，你知道，你可以弄清楚，好吧，如果我们这样准备食物，人们就会生病，如果我们以另一种方式准备食物，他们就不会生病。
And so this kind of, it's like, well, let's do that. Let's do the thing that keeps us from getting sick. They might have had a whole mythology around that. But the idea is that they would for sure tend to teach their children. They would pass that on. And so it becomes kind of a cultural norm without any necessary reason as to why it works, there would just be this sense, this superstitious sense of this is what works. And so folks who don't do that or seem likely not to do those things,
所以这种，这就像是，好吧，让我们这样做。让我们做能让我们免于生病的事情。他们可能围绕这一点有一整套神话。但这个想法是，他们肯定会倾向于教给他们的孩子。他们会把它传下去。所以它就变成了一种文化规范，而不需要任何关于它为什么起作用的必然原因，只会有一种感觉，这种迷信的感觉，这就是起作用的方法。因此，那些不这样做或看起来不太可能做这些事情的人，
people who seem likely to violate these norms were viewed as threats. You've conducted some very interesting studies that suggest that feeling threatened by infectious disease can make people more conformist, more likely to follow rules. And you found this play it's out both at the individual level but at the societal level. Can you talk about that research? Yeah. And that follows directly upon what we were just talking about. So generally speaking, this tendency to be to respond adversely to things that seem like they might pose some sort of threat of infection,
那些看起来可能会违反这些规范的人被视为威胁。你进行了一些非常有趣的研究，表明感到受到传染病威胁会使人们更加墨守成规，更有可能遵守规则。你发现这不仅体现在个人层面，还体现在社会层面。你能谈谈那项研究吗？是的。这紧接着我们刚才讨论的内容。所以总的来说，这种倾向于对似乎构成某种感染威胁的事物做出不利反应的倾向，
whether it's, you know, some thing that actually seems immediately infection. or some person who seems like they might pose a threat of violating norms, we tend to be hypersensitive to these perceived threats under circumstances in which we either are more vulnerable to infection or for whatever reason just kind of feel more vulnerable to infection. And so in psychology experiments, experiments that I've done, experiments that other people have done, we've used manipulations that temporarily just make people
无论是你所知道的实际上似乎立即造成感染的事情，还是任何看起来可能构成违反规范威胁的人，在以下情况下，我们对这些感知到的威胁往往极其敏感：我们要么更容易受到感染，要么出于某种原因只是觉得更容易受到感染。因此，在心理学实验中，我做过的实验，其他人做过的实验，我们使用了暂时让人们
feel a little more freaked out by disease. And we find that when people do feel more freaked out by disease, they tend to be, to endorse more conformist attitudes. They want other people to conform more. And they also are more likely to conform themselves. They are themselves less likely to violate norms, they're more likely to go along with majority opinion and so forth. So that's kind of what's happening at an individual at a psychological level of analysis, but you do see this analogy at a much broader worldwide cultural level of analysis too. So in some countries, simply because of meteorological variables and other sorts of things, some countries tend to just have more infectious diseases going around.
对疾病感到有点恐慌的操控手段。我们发现，当人们确实对疾病感到更加恐慌时，他们往往会支持更多墨守成规的态度。他们希望其他人更加墨守成规。他们也更有可能自己墨守成规。他们自己违反规范的可能性较小，他们更有可能顺从多数人的意见等等。所以这大约是发生在个人和心理分析层面的情况，但在更广泛的全球文化分析层面上，你也看到了这种类比。所以在一些国家，仅仅由于气象变量和其他各种因素，一些国家往往会有更多的传染病四处传播。
And it turns out that in countries that have historically had more infectious diseases, people in general are more conformist. They're more likely to encourage obedience in children. They're more likely to conform to majority opinion themselves. They're more likely to do whatever they can to encourage. not just themselves, but folks around them to uphold existing cultural traditions. You talked about meteorology playing a role here. So are you saying, for example, in the tropics, we always talk about all of these tropical diseases.
事实证明，在历史上传染病更多的国家，人们普遍更加墨守成规。他们更有可能鼓励孩子顺从。他们自己更有可能顺从多数人的意见。他们更有可能尽其所能地鼓励不仅是他们自己，还有他们周围的人去维护现有的文化传统。你刚才谈到气象学在这里发挥作用。所以你是说，例如在热带地区，我们总是谈论所有这些热带疾病。
So that's one of the places where weather would be playing this role, whereas if you live in the Arctic, where it's cold and the germs can't reproduce the way that they can, right, as they can in warmer weather. I'm not a parasitologist, so I hesitate to be on my area of expertise, but that is my understanding that. But that's kind of what we're talking about. There's just more of these harmful bugs, parasites of one sort or another, just more of them can thrive in hotter, wetter places. So do you think that some of this behavioral immune system behavior, particularly around xenophobia and prejudice, is playing out now? during the COVID pandemic, are people becoming more conformist or less so? I mean, the news would tell us that people don't want to get vaccinated, and yet, as you
所以这是天气发挥这种作用的地方之一，而如果你住在北极，那里很冷，细菌无法像在温暖天气那样繁殖。我不是寄生虫学家，所以我不敢超出我的专业领域，但这就是我的理解。但这就是我们正在谈论的。只是有更多这些有害的虫子、各种寄生虫，在更热、更湿润的地方有更多这样的虫子能够繁衍。那么你认为这种行为免疫系统行为的一部分，特别是在仇外心理和偏见周围的行为，现在正在上演吗？在新冠大流行期间，人们是变得更加墨守成规还是不那么墨守成规了？我的意思是，新闻会告诉我们人们不想接种疫苗，然而，正如你
see the numbers creep up and more vaccine becomes available, people are getting vaccinated. So what's at play here? Well, that's a great question, and it's a complicated question because people have particular groups that they seem especially more willing to conform to. So let me go back to the broader question that you asked about whether these kind of phenomena in general seem to be playing out in the pandemic. And it is an empirical question. I'm a scientist, of course. So it's like, I want to see the data.
看到数字不断上升，更多的疫苗变得可用，人们正在接种疫苗。这里面有什么在起作用？这是一个很好的问题，也是一个复杂的问题，因为人们有他们似乎特别愿意顺从的特定群体。所以让我回到你提出的关于这些一般现象是否似乎在大流行中上演的更广泛的问题。这是一个经验问题。我当然是个科学家。所以这就好像，我想看看数据。
And there have been a lot of people who have been collecting data of one sort or another bearing on these kind of questions over the last year. And some of those results are now appearing in academic journals. And there is evidence that some of these things that we've seen in artificial psychology experiments are playing out in the real world. So, for instance, early on in the pandemic, political scientists collected data that was looking at whether the pandemic, the onset of the pandemic was affecting Americans' attitudes toward folks from China specifically, toward Asian Americans, toward immigrant. more broadly, and they found evidence that it was that these more xenophobic responses were being heightened by the onset of the pandemic. There was some work that I saw recently that some psychologists, an international team of psychologists collected data in Poland that showed that the pandemic was associated
过去一年里，有很多人一直在收集与这类问题有关的各种数据。其中一些结果现在正出现在学术期刊上。有证据表明，我们在人工心理学实验中看到的一些事情正在现实世界中上演。例如，在大流行初期，政治学家收集了数据，观察大流行、大流行的爆发是否正在影响美国人对来自中国的人、亚裔美国人、移民的特定态度。更广泛地说，他们发现有证据表明，大流行的爆发正在加剧这些更具仇外心理的反应。我最近看到一些工作，一些心理学家，一个国际心理学家团队在波兰收集了数据，表明大流行与以下因素有关
with an increased endorsement of very traditional attitudes, including. including more negative attitudes to people who violated traditional sexual norms and things like that. So in various different places, we are seeing evidence that some of these phenomena that we just talked about are being exaggerated because of the fact that at a broad population-wide, worldwide level, the pandemic is making
对非常传统态度的认可度增加，包括。包括对违反传统性规范的人更消极的态度等等。所以在各个不同的地方，我们正在看到证据表明，我们刚刚讨论的一些现象正在被夸大，因为在广泛的人口范围、全球范围内，大流行正在使
the threat of disease just kind of extra salient for people in general and people are just in general feeling more vulnerable to the threat of infection. And it's having these these social consequences. There's also research that suggests that the behavioral immune system may influence our choice of mates and our romantic and sexual behavior. Can you talk about that research too? I mean that just sounds fascinating. How does that happen? Well, it's a great question and in fact some of the first work that people people did in this general line of work looked at its effects on people's mate preferences and attraction and so forth.
对于一般人来说，疾病的威胁变得更加突出，人们普遍对感染威胁感到更加脆弱。这带来了一些社会后果。还有研究表明，行为免疫系统可能会影响我们对伴侣的选择以及我们的浪漫和性行为。您能谈谈那项研究吗？我的意思是这听起来太迷人了。这是怎么发生的？这是一个很好的问题，事实上，人们在这个总体方向上做的一些早期工作着眼于它对人们的伴侣偏好和吸引力等方面的影响。
One line of work looks at physical attractiveness in the extent to which people prioritize physical attractiveness in a potential mate. And work shows that in places, for instance, that we're where diseases have historically been more prevalent, people place a higher priority on physical attractiveness. So why might that be? And the answer, there's a couple of answers possible. One is that generally speaking, physical attractiveness serves as kind of a quick and dirty proxy for health.
有一系列研究着眼于身体吸引力以及人们在潜在伴侣中优先考虑身体吸引力的程度。研究表明，例如，在历史上疾病更普遍的地方，人们对身体吸引力的优先级更高。那这可能是为什么呢？答案有几种可能。首先，一般来说，身体吸引力可以作为健康的一种快速且粗略的替代指标。
That is, when people are sick, it affects their appearance in a variety of ways. And in general, people find less attractive. So even among folks who are healthy, there's a tendency to just kind of view physical attractiveness as kind of a proxy for health. And in addition to that, people have argued it can also perhaps serve as a proxy for the idea that this person is going to be producing healthy children. So for a variety of reasons, the argument is that with people, when diseases are more prevalent, or when people are more freaked out by the threat of disease, they place a higher priority on physical attractiveness. There's other ways in which the behavioral immune system can affect people's inclinations,
也就是说，当人们生病时，它会以各种方式影响他们的外表。总的来说，人们发现（生病的人）不那么有吸引力。因此，即使在健康的人群中，也有一种倾向，即把身体吸引力看作是健康的一种替代指标。除此之外，人们还认为它或许也可以作为这样一种观念的替代指标，即这个人将会生育健康的后代。因此，出于多种原因，该观点认为，当疾病更普遍时，或者当人们对疾病的威胁感到更恐慌时，他们会将身体吸引力放在更高的优先级上。行为免疫系统影响人们倾向的方式还有其他几种，
their romantic inclinations. There's intimate sexual behavior and just intimate social contact in general poses an interesting dilemma for folks, because on the one hand, we get a lot of benefits from it. Right. But on the other hand, it makes us more vulnerable to the kinds of diseases that people might spread amongst themselves. So there's this kind of constant trade-off,
他们的浪漫倾向。亲密的性行为和普遍的亲密社会接触给人们带来了有趣的困境，因为一方面，我们从中获得了很多好处。对。但另一方面，它让我们更容易受到人们可能在彼此之间传播的各种疾病的侵害。所以存在这种持续的权衡，
and the idea is that people will resolve that trade-off somewhat differently, depending upon whether they are or not, feeling worried about the threat of infectious disease. When people do feel more vulnerable to infectious disease, the idea is that they'll just pull back a little bit from these romantic inclinations. And there's research that shows that people are just less likely to pursue romantic opportunities when they're feeling more worried about disease.
这个想法是，人们对这种权衡的解决会有所不同，这取决于他们是否对传染病的威胁感到担忧。当人们确实对传染病感到更脆弱时，其观点是他们会稍微从这些浪漫倾向中退缩。有研究表明，当人们对疾病感到更加担忧时，他们不太可能去追求浪漫的机会。
And it's not just in the realm of romance either, for that matter. There's work that shows that people, just in general, are less socially gregarious when they're worried about infectious diseases. Because after all, it's not just intimate sexual contact that poses a risk, but close interpersonal contact in general does. And so for the same reasons, close interpersonal contact can, you know, has this tradeoff. There's lots of benefits from hanging out with friends, from meeting new people and so. forth, but it also carries this risk of disease transmission.
而且不仅在浪漫领域是这样。有研究表明，当人们担心传染病时，总的来说，他们的社交活跃度会降低。因为毕竟，不仅亲密的性行为会构成风险，一般的密切人际接触也会。因此，出于同样的原因，密切人际接触会有这种权衡。和朋友出去玩、结识新朋友等等有很多好处，但它也带来了疾病传播的风险。
Consequently, when people are more worried about the threat of disease, they tend to just kind of pull back from social contact. Let's talk for a minute about the role of disgust and how that fits into our behavioral immune system. It obviously plays an important role for us as living beings, but what role is that? What is the purpose of disgust? A lot of people have studied disgust for a lot of years and have suggested a variety of roles that disgust plays. And the idea that this emotional experience that we call disgust has evolved.
因此，当人们对疾病的威胁更加担忧时，他们往往会从社交接触中退缩。我们花一分钟聊聊厌恶感的作用，以及它如何融入我们的行为免疫系统。作为有生命的个体，它显然对我们发挥着重要作用，但那是什么作用？厌恶感的目的是什么？许多人多年来一直在研究厌恶感，并提出了厌恶感所发挥的各种作用。并且这种被称为厌恶感的情绪体验已经进化的观点。
So, for instance, one expert on disgust has suggested that really a long time ago, evolutionarily speaking, disgust or some early version of disgust, distaste, served a function. of just keeping, you know, potentially contaminated food stuff out of our mouth. And since it's through our mouth that a lot of potential infections can happen. And over time, particularly as our ancestors evolved into more and more of kind of a social species discussed kind of evolved and took on it kind of a broader role that we would not just, It didn't just serve as a way of alerting us to the threat of, you know, contaminated food stuffs, but it's kind of a first alert system for the threat of anything that might be
例如，一位厌恶感专家曾建议，从进化论的角度来看，很久以前，厌恶感或某种早期版本的厌恶感（即反感）发挥了一种功能，即把可能受污染的食物挡在我们的口中。因为很多潜在的感染正是通过我们的口发生的。随着时间的推移，特别是当我们的祖先进化成越来越多的社会性物种时，厌恶感进化并承担了一种更广泛的角色，我们不仅，它不仅仅作为一种提醒我们注意受污染食物威胁的方式，而且它成了对任何可能是
contaminating or infectious. And so what disgust does in folks nowadays, it really, like many emotions, it serves as kind of an alarm system. It's sometimes in a really powerful, immediate way is alerting me to, here's a potential threat of infection, and it's leading me to respond in an avoidant way. You've talked about evolution a little bit as we've been chatting here, and I'm wondering over the long term, do you think this pandemic is going to change people's behavior in any lasting way? I think it would be probably silly of me to speculate upon in terms of whether this will actually have evolutionary consequences.
污染性或传染性威胁的第一警报系统。因此，如今厌恶感在人们身上所起的作用，确实像许多情绪一样，充当了一种警报系统。有时它以一种非常强大、直接的方式提醒我，这里有潜在的感染威胁，并引导我做出回避反应。我们在聊天时稍微谈到了进化，我想知道从长期来看，你认为这场大流行会以任何持久的方式改变人们的行为吗？如果我推测这是否会产生实际的进化后果，那可能就太愚蠢了。
But rather, I think where one is likely to see it is in terms of kind of not genetic evolution, but cultural evolution, that the pandemic is likely to have some lasting effects on what kinds of norms govern how people. interact with each other. And I'm sure I'll be wrong about some of this because I've learned from sad experience that it's really hard to predict the future. But I wouldn't be surprised if the tendency for people to be concerned about being in densely populated close physical spaces,
相反，我认为人们可能会看到它的地方，不是在基因进化方面，而是在文化进化方面，即大流行可能会对规范人们如何互动的各种规范产生一些持久的影响。我确信我对其中一些看法是错误的，因为我从悲惨的经验中吸取了教训，即预测未来真的很难。但我不会感到惊讶的是，如果人们倾向于担心身处人口稠密、密闭的物理空间中，
people will be a little bit more resistant for some chunk of time in the future, to going into these kind of crowded places. So the era of mosh pits may be over. Yeah, well, you know, this is why I think it's hard to speculate. People have short memories, right? We'll still do stupid things. And, you know, so I may be less likely personally to dive into a mosh pit two years from now,
在未来的某个时间段内，人们会对去这些拥挤的地方产生更多的抵触情绪。因此，疯狂冲撞（mosh pit）的时代可能已经结束了。是的，好吧，你知道，这就是为什么我认为很难推测。人们的记忆很短，对吧？我们仍然会做愚蠢的事情。而且，你知道，两年后我个人可能不太可能跳进疯狂冲撞的人群中，
but my kids might still be moshers in the future. I think it's really an interesting question because it gets back to this idea that a lot of the things that help serve as buffers against the spread of disease are also taken away things that people value like close interaction. And so I think that because there is such a power, people do have such a powerful need for social contact and so forth that that probably will recover. What I do expect, or at least I'm very interested in seeing this, is the extent to which there will be kind of more of a persistent norm of wearing masks. You know, in many parts of the world, people well before the COVID pandemic tended to wear cloth masks over their faces as a way of helping to, you know, prevent the spread of, you know, just seasonal flu and colds and things like that. Yeah, and so now that's, you know, that's. That may persist. We can't say it's a norm with everyone everywhere,
但我的孩子将来可能仍然会参与疯狂冲撞。我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为它回到了这样一个观点，即许多有助于抵御疾病传播的事物同时也剥夺了人们珍视的事物，比如亲密的互动。因此我认为，由于人们对社会接触等有着如此强大的需求，这种需求可能会恢复。我确实期待的是，或者至少我非常有兴趣看到的是，在多大程度上会有一种更持久的戴口罩规范。你知道，在世界许多地方，人们在新冠大流行之前很久就倾向于在脸上戴布口罩，以此来帮助（你知道）防止（你知道）季节性流感和感冒等疾病的传播。是的，所以现在，你知道，那可能会持续下去。我们不能说这是每个人在任何地方的规范，
but it has become much more of a norm worldwide. And I'm sure that when the pandemic is over, there will be a lot of folks who will be happy to throw their masks away and want to never touch them again. But I also bet that there will be a lot of folks who will hang on to their masks and will break them out pretty regularly during cold and flu season. and it's likely to have a lot of benefits for public health worldwide. Yeah, I mean, it has, right?
但它在世界范围内已经变得更加普遍的规范。我确信，当大流行结束时，会有很多人乐意扔掉他们的口罩，希望再也不碰它们。但我也敢打赌，会有很多人保留他们的口罩，并且在感冒和流感季节会相当定期地把它们拿出来。这很可能会对全球公共卫生带来很多好处。是的，我的意思是，它确实如此，对吧？
The seasonal flu numbers have been way down this year, so it's absolutely working. That's right. Well, last question, what do you think are the most important questions about the behavioral immune system that remain to be answered? What else are you working on? I can't say I'm working on this. I'll speak more broadly on the kinds of things that folks in the broader research community are working on. and what folks are likely to be working on. I think one really interesting question.
今年的季节性流感数字一直在大幅下降，所以它绝对有效。没错。好吧，最后一个问题，你认为关于行为免疫系统还有哪些最重要的问题亟待解答？你还在研究什么？我不能说我正在研究这个。我会更广泛地谈论广大研究界的人们正在研究的各种事情，以及人们可能会研究的事情。我认为一个非常有趣的问题是
HAT goes back to how we opened and talking about that not only is there a behavioral immune system helps us from beginning getting sick in the first place, but there's also the real immune system, these immunological defenses that fight off infections when they do get inside us. And a really interesting question is the extent to which these two different kinds of immune systems, actually talk to each other, how they interact. And there is various hints of work that do suggest that they are related and they're not just fully independent.
这回到了我们的开场白，即不仅有一个行为免疫系统帮助我们从一开始就避免生病，而且还有一个真正的免疫系统，即当感染真正进入我们体内时与之抗争的免疫防御。一个非常有趣的问题是，这两种不同类型的免疫系统在多大程度上进行实际的对话，它们是如何相互作用的。有各种迹象表明它们确实相关，而不仅仅是完全独立的。
So I'll just give you, I'll give you two examples. One example comes from some work that folks have done that shows that when people actually are actually immunologically suppressed, you know, that they're immune. system just isn't working as well. Those folks compared to other folks tend to show more xenophobic responses to foreigners and things like that. The idea being that when people actually are immunocompromised, they compensate by ramping up the behavioral immune system. And here's another example that some colleagues and I did a study on this and some other folks have done similarly. studies that shows that when people perceive things that are that pose a threat of infection
所以我就给你，我给你举两个例子。一个例子来自人们做的一些研究，该研究表明，当人们实际上免疫受损时（你知道，他们的免疫系统根本没有那么好地工作）。与其他人相比，这些人往往对外国人表现出更多的排外反应等。其核心观点是，当人们实际免疫受损时，他们会通过增强行为免疫系统来进行补偿。这里还有另一个例子，我和一些同事就此做了一项研究，其他人也做过类似的研究，研究表明，当人们感知到环境中存在构成感染威胁的事物时
in their environment or when let's say we look at disgusting pictures that it actually tends to ramp up our actual immunological defenses people who do psycho neuroimmunology have known for years that Any kind of stressful event can ramp up our immunological defenses. But even more so than encountering other stressful things, for instance, even more so than looking at pictures that scare the hell out of me, if I look at pictures of people who themselves look sick, that tends to lead my white blood cells to mount a stronger immunological defense against infections.
或者假设我们看到令人厌恶的图片时，它实际上往往会增强我们实际的免疫防御。从事心理神经免疫学的人多年来一直都知道，任何类型的压力事件都可以增强我们的免疫防御。但与遇到其他压力事件相比，甚至比看那些吓死我的图片相比，如果我看那些本身看起来生病的人的照片，这往往会引导我的白血病细胞发起更强的免疫防御来对抗感染。
So it's a different part of the body that's reacting. It's not like a cortisol level. It's white blood cell. So it really is immune suppressing. It's not just a stress response. It actually is an immunological response. So I mean, these are some really interesting hints of how these different kinds of mechanisms, these immunological mechanisms, these psychological mechanisms, are in some way deeply connected.
所以这是身体的不同部分在反应。这不像皮质醇水平。它是白细胞。所以它确实在抑制免疫。这不仅仅是一种压力反应。它实际上是一种免疫反应。所以我的意思是，这些是非常有趣的迹象，表明这些不同类型的机制——这些免疫机制、这些心理机制——在某种程度上是深度相连的。
And some folks have suggested, hey, you know, it probably makes sense to talk about this as all part of the body's integrated means of of defending against infectious diseases and within an evolutionary framework it makes sense that these things would all be kind of deeply connected in some way so a really interesting line of work and I think it'll take years of work ahead is to kind of sort out how the behavioral immune system interacts with the real immune system. So that's just one example of something I think is going to be really important and interesting. Well, thank you for joining us today, Dr. Scha.
一些人建议，嘿，你知道，把它作为身体抵御传染疾病的综合手段的一部分来讨论可能是有意义的，并且在进化框架内，这些事情在某种程度上都是深度相连的，这是有道理的。因此，一个非常有趣的研究方向——我认为这将需要未来数年的工作——是弄清楚行为免疫系统如何与真实的免疫系统相互作用。这只是我认为将非常重要和有趣的事情的一个例子。好吧，谢谢你今天加入我们，沙博士。
This has been really interesting. I think you've given us a lot to think about as we make our way through the pandemic and flu season and the whole winter. I appreciate you spending time with us today. It's been a pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology. or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts,
这真的很有趣。我认为在我们度过大流行、流感季节和整个冬天的过程中，你给我们提供了很多需要思考的事情。我很感激你今天花时间陪我们。这是一种荣幸。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.com 或您获取播客的任何地方找到往期的《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）节目。如果您对未来的播客有评论或想法，
you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org at speaking of psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您可以给我们发电子邮件：speaking of psychology at APA.org（speaking of psychology 是一个词），网址是 APA.org。本期《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·孔丁（Chris Kondyne）。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills），代表美国心理学会（American Psychological Association）。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。